[Musique]
ils sont pleinement engagés dans la
recherche et le développement le
laboratoire national de métrologie et
d'essai dont le site est situé attrapés
pour en parler nous sommes avec le
directeur général adjoint dû aller ne
thomas gennari bonjour bonjour
[Rires]
notre métier où aller nous c'est de
travailler avec tout ce qui est
innovation technologique 1 ceci pour lui
donner un cadre de référence quand on a
une nouvelle technologie qui arrive ce
sont toujours les mêmes questions qui se
posent ça peut être des questions de
performance est ce qu'on peut en avoir
pour son argent est ce que les
performances au moins être atteinte
ça peut être aussi des questions de
robustesse à ce que les performances
vont être là dans l'environnement réel
d'utilisation de la technologie
et puis aussi ça peut être des questions
de sécurité par se plante on a une
nouvelle technologie on peut toujours
avoir des effets qui ne sont pas
souhaitées et il est important de
pouvoir les détecter les mesures et pour
pouvoir les apprécier
vous êtes un organisme public rattaché
au ministère de l'économie et des
finances qui sont vos clients
alors nos clients sont à la fois des
départements des des ministères des
clients publics et puis aussi beaucoup
de clients privés qui viennent vers nous
pour venir tester leurs produits avant
de les commercialiser pour être certain
qu'ils vont donner le niveau de
performances inattendues comme je vous
le disais à l'instant voir pour sonder
d'éventuels effets qui ne serait pas
qu'ils ne seraient pas souhaité et puis
ça peut être aussi des essais ils sont
réalisés dans le cadre de démarches de
certification
la certification c'est être le chose qui
est très utile parce que voilà on a ça
permet d'avoir une réponse simple oui
c'est bon ou non ça ne marche pas et
donc pour délivrer cette certification
il faut faire des essais et c'est là que
le elle est venue intervient si on faire
un focus sur le site de trappes un duel
haineux combien de personnes ça
représente et quelles sont les missions
de ses collaborateurs donc sur le site
de trappes
on a à peu près 450 collaborateurs qui
interviennent dans les domaines de la de
l'électricité la chimie les essais ans
environnement donc tout ça ça permet
d'avoir un ensemble très cohérent et qui
répond à tous les besoins de nos clients
industriels est aussi dont clients
publics et là où vous êtes en cours de
construction d'un projet la plateforme
l'eia c'est une plateforme qui sera
dédiée à l'évaluation de l'intelligence
artificielle
c'est un investissement d'un peu plus de
700000 euros dont 390 mille euros du
plan de relance de l'état
oui c'est ça donc ce financement du plan
de relance on en est très heureux c'est
formidable pour nous un déjà je voudrais
remercier l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines et puis aussi la
région ile-de-france qui nous ont
soutenus pour avoir ce financement dont
2 390 mille euros c'est un financement
tendues dans le cas de la
réindustrialisation des territoires
alors si on s'intéresse aux territoires
de l'évaluation de l'intelligence
artificielle
en fait on voit que on en a on en a pas
beaucoup un des gens qui font la même
chose que nous en fait on a notre
homologue aux états unis à washington le
nist on a le n 2 i à tokyo au japon
et puis il ya maintenant le haineux à
saint quentin en yvelines dont le voyez
si on fait cette carte de l'évaluation
bâtiments officiels maintenant on peut
dire
washington tokyo
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ça c'est très
bien et pour parler plus en détails de
ce projet on va rejoindre votre
responsable de l'évaluation de
l'intelligence artificielle guillaume a
droit
[Musique]
m
attendons
bonjour guillaume à brens bon alors
nicolas
[Musique]
vous êtes le responsable de l'évaluation
de l'intelligence artificielle sur le
site de trappes duel haineux alors on va
parler de la plateforme l'eia les ja
c'est le laboratoire d'évaluation de
l'intelligence artificielle
un projet sur lequel vous travaillez
actuellement en quoi ça consiste en fait
en fait c'est la première plateforme
générique de mesure et d'évaluation de
l'intelligence artificielle
son objectif c'est d'être en mesure de
caractériser et l'environnement de
fonctionnement de ces systèmes
intelligents c'est à dire d'être capable
de dire quand est ce qu'il fonctionne
et quand est-ce qu'il ne fonctionne pas
c'est une plate forme que vous
développez actuellement qui sera lancée
au premier semestre 2022
c'est destiné à qui en fait alors cesser
une effectivement on l'a finalisera en
c'est une plateforme qui est destiné à
l'ensemble des acteurs qui développe ou
qui utilisent des technologies
d'intelligence artificielle pour les
développeurs l'objectif ça va être de
finalement effectivement caractériser
leur produit peut-être le benchmark et
faire des analyses comparatives de
performance par rapport à la concurrence
est capable d'identifier les briques
technologiques qui sont les plus
performantes
avant le lancement commercial du produit
et côté utilisateurs finaux de ces
technologies intelligentes
il ya un certain il ya un grand nombre
de produits du hac qui existent sur le
marché
et l'objectif va être de leur donner des
outils qui vont leur permettre de
choisir en connaissance de cause
parmi les différentes techno qui existe
l'idée c'est aussi de rassurer je
suppose
autour de cette thématique de
l'intelligence artificielle comptons pas
sur un robot fut un jour pour
caricaturer un peu mais c'est ce à quoi
tout à fait c'est tout à fait ça
l'objectif avait de mettre à disposition
des outils d'évaluation de qualification
et certification des systèmes dia on
sait que l'intelligence artificielle ses
impacts
quasiment tous les secteurs industriels
et de notre vie domestique avec les
robots agricole les robots des aides à
la personne des dispositifs médicaux
intelligents les systèmes de mobilité
autonome donc il ya un réel besoin
d'acceptabilité conservant ses systèmes
dia mais c'est aussi un outil qui va
permettre aux industriels de
de notre écosystème national et européen
d'avoir dédié à qui sont plus
performantes plus fiable et du coup ça
contribuera on l'espère et c'est notre
objectif à la relance de notre économie
de notre industrie
merci guillaume havrin maintenant
responsable d'évaluation de
l'intelligence artificielle sur le site
de trappes et donc le projet l'eia qui
se développe ici à saint quentin en
yvelines lancement de cette plateforme
au premier semestre 2022
[Musique]